did you miss your chance to play red  dead redemption on xbox one turns out no  one was supposed to be playing it this  past weekend some xbox live users manage  to get rockstars Western working on  their consoles through the backwards  compatibility function but according to  Microsoft the whole thing was an error  Microsoft's Major Nelson took to Twitter  to explain the situation saying that all  xbox 360 games are tested through an  emulator something on Microsoft's and  made these private games briefly  available to the public but you won't be  able to grab any of them now in fact  Microsoft stated that anyone who did  could be held in violation of their code  of conduct those who got their hands on  the game said I played well on xbox one  so if red dead redemption becomes truly  available via backwards compatibility we  should be in for a good time for now  Microsoft is in talks with Rockstar  about bringing the game over if that  happens we'll tell you all about it on  gamespot